keep his king safe there are two big
threats in the position firstly this one
checkmate in one but secondly the white
knight also jumping across and trapping
this king in the corner
and uh simply nothing to do if you step
forward with your pawn there's a
beautiful finish here this black bishop
guards this square now but you can
distract it
get it away
give a check and after the one rook is
captured this other rook gives checkmate
okay we're gonna see this on the board
as we showed this black rook steps back
to defend this square but now the white
knight jumps in and checkmate inevitable
very good oh
very very nice uh mating pattern there
yeah and the two white knights talked
about them they're tricky yeah very
tricky yeah they are very tricky and uh
king in the corner
that's always a sign that you should be
careful and
oh look at jordan yeah he knows it is
over there's nothing he can do
he's going to show the checkmate to us
wow and uh okay it was checkmate in one
here after black's bishop takes one
night the knight replaces it and